hey everybody welcome back to the ski
resort I'm sorry this episode took a
while to make I had a number of
technical difficulties and hiccups along
the way but here we are and there are
two videos on screen right now and
you're probably wondering why that is Oh
first of all I recorded this entire
episode and I forgot to save the park
afterwards which is something that I'm
very good at doing and it's really
getting on my nerves that I keep doing
this but in this case I still had all of
my footage I just lost all of the
progress that I made so I decided to use
this as an opportunity to do a fun
little experiments and rerecord the
entire thing try to rebuild what I
originally built with a few small
changes here and there and see to what
extent when you do something a second
time you do it better and faster than
you did the first time so you can see my
original and first recording that I lost
the progress off in the top right screen
and then the rest of the screen is
filled up by the new recording which is
progress that actually kept and the
question is will I be faster and will I
improve in some things on my second
attempts and I can probably spoil
already that I did end up doing things
about faster I did decide not to do more
so at some point during the video we'll
switch back to the old recording and
that's when you'll notice just how much
faster I was able to do stuff the second
time around
anyway onto what I'm actually doing in
this video the bulk of this episode is
made up of me making an artificial lake
as you can see here I'm already quite a
bit further ahead in my second recording
than in my first one but you're probably
wondering what the reason is for the
artificial lake at least if you're not
too familiar with ski resorts so in the
first and second episode I installed
snow lenses everywhere which are these
metal poles with the orange banks at the
bottom which create artificial snow now
the thing is the way that these things
work is very complicated and I can't
really explain it exactly but they need
compressed air and a water supply
they shoot it into the air in such a way
that by the time these particles fall
down
they'll have accumulated into snow
particles and again I don't know exactly
how this process works there's a lot of
interesting physics involved there then
I'm not quite equipped to explain but
it's how these things work regardless
and it means that if you have snow
lenses in a ski resort you need to have
some kind of water supply and typically
ski resorts will create artificial lakes
to store water to use to make artificial
snow with it so somebody pointed this
out in the comments of my last video I
think and I thought it was a good piece
of feedback to add a lake which I
completely forgot about earlier so
thanks for that comment by the way and
thanks for the comments in general
they've been really nice and I've got a
lot of good feedback and lots of great
tips and I'll definitely come back to
some of that feedback later in this
episode and in future episodes as well
anyway as you can see by now I've made
quite a bit more progress on my second
attempt than my first one and the lake
is already finished on that one and I
still need to finish some things about
the lake on my first attempt I also
changed a few things I put that fence
around the lake border itself on the new
attempts because on the old one is what
it was way too far away from the lake
I was figuring that there would be a
path between the fence and the lake but
in hindsight that's kind of a slip'n
hazard so I didn't want people to slip
into the lake and slipping down the
right side of the hillside wouldn't
really be as dangerous so I put the
fence around the lake as it probably
should have been all along I also
changed the look of the lake overall as
you can see on the new attempt I have
very clean cuts concrete borders whereas
on the old one the snow is kind of
overhanging into the lake
which looked like a thicker pack of snow
then I think that should really be in
the park and overall I just didn't look
quite as clean as the new attempt so I
think that's a slight improvement I know
as well I also put lights around
the old Lake but in hindsight this Lake
is really just here for functional
reasons there's no reason for a fancy
walkway maybe in the summer you'll often
find that these lakes are being used for
some kind of recreational activities in
the summer which is pretty cool I might
at that at some later stage but for now
it's really just functional and that's
what I'm focusing on
I'm also building this small wooden shed
for no actual reason other than it just
looked nice and I wanted to try adding
something to at least have an extra
building in here and not just have
everything be trees but obviously I'm
gonna have to add some more buildings in
the future as well I got some
recommendations for an opera ski bar
which i think is very important one of
those round pavilions there's two iconic
not to include or some kind of
restaurants or in general some buildings
at the bottom of the valley to make a
little small village to some extent
anyway I actually wanted to also talk in
this episode a bit more about artificial
snow making and how it works as I'm
still working on this lake here because
I think it's a really interesting topic
especially because it's become more and
more important in the last few decades
really the reason why I decided to add
artificial snow into this ski resorts is
because at least here in northwestern
Europe a ski resort just doesn't look
realistic without these especially on a
low elevation which judging by the the
size and shape of these mountains this
resort would definitely be it's becoming
increasingly necessary in the last
couple of decades due to climate change
I swear I don't want to get too
political in my planet coaster videos
but at this point especially in ski
resorts it's become increasingly clear
that climate change has been happening
and while it's been affecting different
regions in different ways it seems like
the Alps and surrounding areas in Europe
are losing a lot of snow days per year
glaciers are retreating quite a bit and
many ski resorts are actually losing
their certainty that there will be snow
in the snow season hence more and more
ski resorts have been investing in
artificial snow in the last couple
decades and you see especially these
snow lenses popping up everywhere
although there are also other methods of
making snow like snow cannons or snow
fans depending on what you want to call
them but those aren't available in the
workshop and I tried building them but
there are really barely any good pieces
for that available and planet coaster
and besides I think snow lenses are
realistic to add into this resort anyway
because it looks like everything would
be recently renovated in this resort the
lifts and stuff are new for instance and
nowadays you often find snow lenses
being built because as far as I'm aware
they are cheaper than traditional snow
fans even though the snow is of
different quality and perhaps not quite
as good which is definitely a thing by
the way and I think any people who have
skied before and who have skied on
artificial snow before can attest to the
fact that artificial snow really feels
different from French powder snow I
don't think it's quite as good and I
think it's really terrible either but
it's definitely kind of a last resort
that said it's a very important last
resort I've definitely also been in
situations here in the Alps at least
that the entire mountains are just
completely green and there's no snowfall
at all and really you're just skiing on
a small strip of artificial snow in the
middle of a green meadow which is a kind
of sucks but at least it makes me that
art of snow is here I think it's quite
an important infrastructure in ski
resorts nowadays because despite being
extremely expensive because the
infrastructure is is quite extensive you
need you need the artificial lakes you
need to install all the snow lenses but
then you also need to install all the
pipelines that connect this entire
system together it's really some of the
most expensive and also well it takes a
lot of electricity to run this whole
kinds of system so the fact that the ski
resorts are investing in this so much
really shows how important this is to
keep ski resorts running if
if it's not to provide all of their snow
which is usually hopefully not the case
it at least provides certainty that if
you're booking a ski trip in advance and
this might be a couple of months in
advance and it's very expensive you at
least want to have certainty that you'll
be able to ski be it on natural snow
which of course would be nicer but it
might as well be on artificial snow if
there's nothing else available so yeah
all together it's quite important for
this episode actually decided to read a
bunch of articles I guess I'll link that
down in the description it's not really
a citation or anything but just if
you're interested in the topic there's a
bunch of interesting information about
it there are even some people who are
arguing that despite the fact that
artificial snow takes a lot of
electricity it also might curb some
albedo effects and in that sense curb
effects of emissions but I'm not
entirely sure to what extent that is
really true but it's definitely very
much true that climate change is posing
a threat to the skiing industry here in
North Western Europe and in Central
Europe and that as such the industry has
been reacting to that in a lot of
different ways what's also interesting
is that artificial snow does seem to
have a kind of effect on the surfaces of
the mountains and affecting the soil and
vegetation in these areas in a negative
way but regardless of that I think for
these resorts at least it's become too
important at the moment to let it slip
what's also interesting is that ski
resorts are focusing more and more on
summer activities at least for
winterberg I know for instance that
recent years they've been much more busy
in the summer and some summer months
have even been busier than the key
winter months because they're focusing
more on mountain biking and things like
that and using the ski lifts which are
going to be increasingly difficult to
use for skiing for other activities as
well
there was also some irony in me
recording in this episode right now
because as you might know I started this
series when Belgium had an extreme
heatwave a couple of weeks ago that was
in June that June turned out to be the
hottest June in Belgium of all time and
last week and I was trying to record
this video we hit the hottest two days
in Belgium's recorded history finally
hitting over 40 degrees Celsius for the
first time I even had to stop recording
because my CPU is overheating which was
not that great okay yeah I guess that's
the one theme attic link in this episode
anyway at this point you can see that
the old recording has come back to the
front stage and the new one is basically
finished and I want to take this time to
explain some of the things that I've
been doing because these things have
been basically identical from the old
recording to the new one and it's mostly
related to feedback that I got on the
first two videos so over here I'm adding
some fences or really some nets to
protect skiers from their own dumb
impulses I suppose now to prevent skiers
from skiing into ski lifts which will
very often see and I'm also placing some
of these nuts on the sides of very steep
valleys as I just did on that little
part going through the forest or from
areas where you can't go back to any
piece anymore I'm also adding quite a
bunch of foliage especially underneath
the ski lifts I had a bunch of comments
about how barren the land was underneath
the ski lift which I agree definitely
shouldn't be so under the assumption
that the ski lifts would have been
installed a few years ago and now you
can see nature blossoming underneath
them once again
I'm adding some very small spruces
underneath the lifts and also some tree
stumps from trees that would have been
cut to cut this line through the forest
and some smaller slight adjustments as
well I'm adding some terrain paint
everywhere to make the land underneath
the trees uh no II and kind of dirty not
only a sense of being healthy but you
know showing the soil and dirt
underneath the trees where the snow
doesn't really fall down and adding some
ground shrubbery as well because crunch
rubbery is pretty important and I'm not
going to add too much of this because
there's a lot of foliage in this map but
especially around the sides of the piste
and underneath the ski lifts I think
you'd find a lot of this I also tried
the some extent to use it to demarcate
where the piste would start because in
real life you can usually very easily
tell what's groomed and what isn't
groomed and in that sense channel Watts
peace and what isn't
but in planet coaster that's a bit more
difficult because well it's not as
keying simulator so we don't have ground
textures for groomed or ungroomed snow
so I'm using some of the rougher snow to
paints the areas that aren't piste and
using me completely flats clear snow to
demarcate what is the piste
area and I think that works alright it's
not perfect but at least you can kind of
tell the difference between snow that's
accumulating alongside the forest and
snow that you're supposed to ski on and
I guess related to this I had some
suggestions to add some moguls to one of
the black beasts which I think it's an
amazing idea and I would love to do
something like that I tried and messed
with terraforming to do it and with some
of the snow pieces that we have in game
but neither of them looks really good I
felt like the moguls looks kind of
unrealistic and unbelievable
so I decided against the idea but maybe
one day
I do find a way to make them
realistically but for now I don't know I
thought it was a bit too strange-looking
to really go through with that idea but
I love it and maybe one day I do end up
doing something like that
there was also an idea to do a fun park
but that's the topic that I'm going to
save for the next episode but I do want
to say I'm not going to be very good at
it because I've never really skied on
any terrain parks or at least I've been
on them but I'm a total wuss and I'm a
total newb so really I've only been on
boxes and I've never actually done jumps
or anything like that but I'll try my
best
later to do something like that anyway
we're getting near the end of the
episode here I'm just finalizing this
fence alongside this this road going up
the mountain which is I have to say
getting a bit annoying because as
awesome as the scheme priests are these
skiing
items are they do also have the rotation
issue that you see with a lot of TMT K
items where you really need to use the
3d gizmo to place each of them that that
was a bit annoying but you know that
aside not doing too bad there and that's
the end of this episode so I'd like to
thank you guys for watching and I hope
to see you in the next one
[Music]